am tag des imf gipfels das phoenix tages
gespräch mit dr andreas gassen
vorstandsvorsitzende der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung
schönen guten tag herr gassen
heute soll beim it gipfel der
bundesregierung mit den ländern
oberhäuptern auch über das impfen in
arztpraxen gesprochen werden herr gassen
sie vertreten die interessen der etwa
116.000 niedergelassenen ärzte in
deutschland was wünschen sie sich vom
impfgipfel heute abend also im interesse
unserer mitbürger wünsche ich mir dass
der impf gipfel heute der zweite
erkenntnis kommt dass die eigentliche
geschwindigkeit beim impfen nur erreicht
werden kann wenn die niedergelassenen
praxen einbezogen werden und dass sobald
impfstoff in ausreichender menge zur
verfügung steht
aber das ist ja offenbar das problem
dass eben nicht genug bisher zur
verfügung steht und deshalb die ärzte
dann wenn mehr dafür da ist eben auch
dann mehr bekommen ja das ist das
problem bisher gewesen jetzt hatten wir
ja zwischendurch noch den kurzen
aussetzer mit astrazeneca der gott sei
dank ja wieder zugelassen ist mit einer
etwas erweitert erweiterten aufklärung
wir erwarten auch neue impfstoffe im
laufe des quartals aber sie haben recht
mit denen aktuell zugelassenen
impfstoffen werden wir uns im zweiten
quartal 21 bei 60 bis knapp 70 millionen
impfstoffdosen bewegen aber das ist
natürlich schon deutlich mehr als im
ersten quartal
und das ist eine größenordnung die durch
die impfung natürlich nicht verimpft
werden kann
das ist interessant sagt sie das sagen
60 bis 70 millionen sie haben ja schon
mal gesagt den letzten wochen das sie im
april sich vorstellen können dass dann
monatlich 20 millionen menschen geimpft
werden
ist das tatsächlich noch realistisch
weil ich habe tatsächlich eben mal die
zahlen so zusammen hat die anordnung auf
der seite des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums geschaut
und die impfdosen die ich da so sehe die
kommen soll die klingen für mich nicht
nach im april 20 millionen dosen man im
april wird das auch noch knapp werden
die impfstoff nicht vom wachsen ja auf
die kapazitäten werden sukzessive
natürlich erhöht und wir haben ja ein
bisschen das problem gehabt dass wir
durch die eu kommission
ein wenig ans ende der schlange der
impfstoff empfang empfangen gekommen
sind so jetzt wendet sich das langsam
ein so dass sicherlich anfang april
diese geschätzte größeren von 56
millionen die woche noch nicht erreicht
hat aber im laufe des april und anfang
mai wird es auf diese größen
hinauslaufen so dass die 20 millionen
dann wahrscheinlich im mai sicher
realistisch wären vorher wird es noch
weniger sein das ist wichtig sind denn
ihre 116000 ihre gelassene ärzte bereit
loszulegen und auch zu impfen sind da
alle voraussetzungen da und sind die
ärzte überhaupt willig ist das lukrativ
genug für die schaffen die das überhaupt
in ihrem arbeitsablauf einzubauen also
kurzum sind sie bereit also 100.000 haus
und facharztpraxen wir sind wir davon
ausgegangen nur 50.000 würden sich
anfangs beteiligen für mehr ist im
moment wahrscheinlich auch gar keinen
impfstoff da bereits sind die natürlich
weil impfen in den praxen völlig normal
ist im impfzentrum ist es natürlich
ungewöhnlich haben auch gesehen dass
geht das war aber es geht mit einem
enormen überbau der letztlich häufig in
messehallen fußball tz ausstattung also
nicht das übliche impf ambiente das ist
tatsächlich in entwachsen bei den haus-
und fachärzten die können das und machen
das jedes jahr bei der grippeimpfung
völlig geräuschlos lukrativ über die ist
jetzt nicht das ist ja sicherlich nicht
von den kollegen als
geldbeschaffungsmaßnahmen gedacht wenn
man glück haben decken die erstattung
kosten
die aufwände in den praxen aber ich
glaube es ist dateien wir mit den mit
der bevölkerung eine ganz große großen
wunsch auf normalität und deshalb sind
alle kollegen kollegen bereit und wollen
auch helfen diese pandemie möglich
schnell griff zu kriegen das wird nur
mit impfungen gelingen insofern gehen
sie von einer hohen bereitschaft der
niedergelassenen ärzteschaft aus dass
wir das in den griff bekommen sollte man
die starre und die klar vorgegebene im
priorisierung aufweichen aus ihrer sicht
also dass beispielsweise wenn jetzt eine
ganze familie kommt in der dann eine
person eben geimpft werden soll dass man
daneben auch sagt komm wir im zweifel
gleich den rest der familie mit weil was
wir schon mal da haben das haben wir
schon mal erledigt also die im
priorisierung war natürlich umso
wichtiger je knapp dem stoff fordern das
hat sich an den sinkenden todeszahlen
gezeigt dass es richtig war dass wir die
hochbeete
fakten zu impfen weil die das höchste
risiko haben zu schwer zu erkranken zu
versterben also da haben wir mehr effekt
von einigen wochen impfen gesehen als
von fünf wochen lockt da wenn sich die
impfstoffmenge steigert dann ist es
natürlich vollkommen richtig und es dort
genau das zu was sie sagen es muss
irgendwann natürlich auch dazu kommen
dass wir gesunde und mobile menschen
impfen wenn wir die kranken
weitestgehend durch haben weil natürlich
erstens nur so eine herrn immunität
erreicht werden kann und menschen die
beispielsweise im berufsleben stehen
nehmen sie die supermarktkasse hier
nehmen sie den straßen mannschaft die
also jeden tag kontakt mit vielen
menschen ist natürlich hoch sind voll
die auch zu impfen
das muss man trotzdem in einer gewissen
priorisierung machen weil wir neben den
hoch betrag noch andere priorisierung
gruppen haben aber ich glaube in der
form dass wir zunehmend mehr impfstoff
bekommen kann diese priorisierung ein
stück weit in den hintergrund treten
also ich sag mal im april sagen sie
müsste sich dann langsam die im chor
sierung aufweichen
ich denke das wird sich im laufe des
april bis mai dann zunehmend so
gestalten und natürlich sollte nicht
wahllos impfen
aber wenn eine praxis bei regen unter
200 dosen in der woche bekommt und hat
100 1560 an
hochbetagt und chronisch kranke geimpft
und dann sind in der woche keine anderen
ohne schranken mehr verfügbar dann macht
es sicher sind diese 40 dosen an auch an
jüngere und gesunde zu verhelfen
frage sie haben sich im oktober klar
gegen einen lock down ausgesprochen der
dann doch kam ihr vize chef der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung der hat nun
etwa so vor einem monat noch einmal
gesagt ein dauer lockdown sei keine
option aber in dem sind wir ja er
spricht er aber tatsächlich viele
menschen auch aus der seele wie sieht
ihre option für die nächsten wochen und
monate aus also der locker und jetzt im
fünften monat ist natürlich ein gewisses
auch irgendwo ausdruck der hilflosigkeit
das muss man so deutlich sagen wir haben
letztes jahr im oktober ja durchaus
diskutiert das papier herausgehoben wie
gesagt haben lockt das wird uns auch die
dauer nicht retten das zeigt sich jetzt
wir brauchen alternativen maßnahmen bis
wir impfen können das ist unvollständig
geschehen das ist in teilen geschehen
aber wir stellen fest lockern hat es zum
beispiel nicht geschafft die todeszahlen
relevant zu reduzieren werden
zwischenzeitlich über 1000 tote am tag
erst mit dem einschreiten der impfung
ist es dass ich zur reduktion der
todestag gekommen deshalb müssen wir auf
dem weg des impfens weiter
voranschreiten das ist das was uns
aus corona für das zeug die usa das soll
das zeugnis auch großbritannien
verlassen und verlassen wenn sie sagen
dass das reicht so nicht das ist ein
ausweis von hilflosigkeit ich zitiere
sie da was muss dann aus ihrer sicht
noch passieren außer mehr impfen
der impfstoff ist ja im moment nicht da
bei dem stoff kommt das ist zumindest
ein hoffnungsschimmer man kann das ganze
begleitet von einer intelligenten test
strategie die wird ja versucht das ist
jetzt auch nicht trivial aber natürlich
auch im test mengen braucht und man muss
glaube ich auch klar definieren was sind
wirklich risiko treiber und wir haben
uns ja monatelang an dingen die
restaurants und friseurläden
festgebissen und haben letztlich keine
wirkliche reduktion der infektionszahlen
in bekommen weil wir das ist immer noch
so in großen teilen nicht wissen wo der
großteil der infektion geschieht jetzt
kommen noch die mutationen dazu die
ohnehin ansteckender sind so dass es
sehr schwierig war die zahlen ohne
impfung und der strategie überhaupt zu
kontrollieren
jetzt wollen wir hoffen dass wir es noch
so lange hin bekommen bis die impfung in
größerem umfang erreichen aber es zeigt
auch völlig klar dass ideen wie endo
oder zero cobit einfach völlig an der
realität vorbeigehen das virus ist so
omnipräsent dass wir es nur mit einer
vernünftigen impfkampagne nachhaltig in
den griff bekommen es bleibt die
hoffnung um auch da sie zu zitieren dr
andreas klassen vorstandsvorsitzende der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung
vielen dank herr im phoenix
tagesgespräch